i talk about the three as i was taught
the three cancers
of the mind which are complaining
comparing and criticizing
the complaining comparing and
criticizing are at lower frequencies and
vibration
right so if you're trying to operate
from the point of view of like
being a growth mindset person being a
person who wants to help others
being a good person that vibration is
bringing you down and that doesn't mean
that you reject people who do that or
you don't care about them and you just
push them away
but it's you also recognizing that if
you have a different goal
you're not going to be able to achieve
that from this frequency and vibration
now you may get to a point in your life
where you're strong enough to lift
people up
but until you're at that level you know
you're going to get pulled down and i
often think about
the idea of if you saw someone drowning
in the sea if you were lifeguard
qualified you'd go and save them but if
you weren't you'd go look for the
lifeguard i believe that each and every
one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the
podcast
is the amazing jay shetty he's a
best-selling author
podcast host of his own show called on
purpose
he's a former monk and a purpose coach
and what really came from this
conversation is just
how on purpose he really is with his
life he wrote a new book called think
like a monk
and there are so many examples
in the book and calls to action and
techniques
about how to truly get to the core
of yourself and to look inward and to
start to realize what fear can do for
you
and what it's signifying jay is such a
wonderful sharer
he has so many real examples and we just
had a really cool conversation where we
were not only talking about
his life in the past but also the future
and where it's going
and perhaps maybe what we're being
called to do
thanks for doing this oh thank you danny
good thank you so much for having me
i've been wanting to meet you for so
long so this is a really
good in me thank you i feel like it's a
long time coming but it was good it's
all right on time just like
everything in the world it's all just
right on time so how's
how's 2020 been for you i mean i feel
like this is like got to be like the
most standard first question
but i don't think there's a way we can
avoid this question because
it's been a year of so much shifting
and trauma and drama and growth and
lessons and challenges
and so like can you encapsulate the way
this year has gone for you
yeah i think 2020 has been a year that
i probably needed personally in some
ways
and at the same time it's i know
for others been a year that they have
lost someone or lost something
and it's been truly crazy and
had such a profound impact on the way
they live and
what they do and their career and so
first of all i
i lost a few people this year through
kobe 2 and so
my heart goes out to anyone who lost
anyone during this time and
at the same time when i look at it from
a purely individual perspective for
myself
this year really gave me the stillness
and the clarity that i potentially
despite my attempts to be still
and mindful potentially could have even
missed because
there's something really powerful when
everyone has to stop
and reflect and pause and question
and so for me i think it was the
most uninvited unwelcomed stillness
that has really really helped me this
year and
in a way that i didn't expect and it was
completely surprised
yeah it it it brings me to a thought
i've had many times lately and this is
about
spiritual teachers and gurus and leaders
and
it's that
nobody's perfect and that in fact
these are the people almost that we're
needing it the most right because that's
i mean otherwise why would you ever be
so
interested in this arena is uh other
than the fact that it's what you need as
well
and so i think that it's really
beautiful
and humble and
transparent to share that even though
okay okay like i think like a monk and i
was a monk
and i encouraged stillness and breathing
and meditation
that it's something that you needed as
well
yeah i and i i couldn't i'd be lying if
i said that wasn't the case
because everything is about
depth and levels and so no matter how
deep you are there's a whole universe
that is still yet to be explored
and i feel like we understand that
when we think about the outside world so
if you think about how many countries
have you been to and how many cities
have you been to and
how many mountains did you travel to the
top of or how many valleys did you go
and visit
when you explore an outward space you
recognize that you
have not understood
the incredible vast nature of the planet
we live on
and so when you think about going inward
we have to realize that that's
almost a more infinite journey and so
for me
i consider myself to be a mindful still
reflective individual and it was
i was i did i had no idea what levels
and
and depths were even more possible that
were achieved during this time
uh in in a way of surprise and so yes i
i
i thank you for for noticing that but
for me it's
it's very real uh and and i'm so
grateful for that experience
because potentially i could have missed
some of this stuff for years
and time could have just gone by and i
think that's the hard thing
about change in transition in years like
2020
is that they make us awake to everything
all at once
and that's why it can seem overwhelming
but if
in that overwhelm we can pinpoint
the areas and the essence
of what we need to do then it's almost
like that overwhelm can help us push
towards the right opportunity
yeah let's unpack that you know i was
thinking of the saying new level new
devil that's exactly what it sounds like
when you're saying like the new the
levels and there's
depth to it um but when let's say when
you get into this space where you're
starting to recognize something that
needs to be
shifted unpacked realized
transformed like what's that like like
what is
how does that go how do you where
what do you become aware of what
feelings do you get
and then like what do you do what's your
process
i think the first thing is i try and
look at it
like a magic trick or the reaction to a
magic trick
so i try and approach it with that sheer
enthusiasm and joy and surprise of like
wow but from a magic trick perspective
so if you
i'm a the reason why i said magic trick
is i'm a big fan of david blaine and
darren brown
and if if you see a magic trick
and you see that response and reaction
someone has you're shocked as to how
you didn't see that coming but the shock
feeling is of
joy and enthusiasm and surprise not of
worry and fear
and i find that a lot of the time when
we discover we haven't been doing
something
we usually judge ourselves we rush from
discovery to judgment
and judgment creates fear a feeling of
regret
and and a feeling of self sabotage
almost of like why haven't i done it i
should have started this how did i miss
this
oh my gosh i messed up and so we start
creating this
rhetoric and this pattern of judging
ourselves
whereas for me and this was definitely
what we were trained in as monks it's
that
you almost have this childlike reaction
to discovery
it's like if a child is digging away in
a in a
treasure hunt and discovers a p
discovers a piece of treasure
they're not going to be like why didn't
i find this 10 minutes ago they're just
going to be elated that they discovered
it and so when you
find something out about yourself
i find that the easiest way to approach
it is with that
enthusiasm joy and surprise so that's
that's step one
after that discovery now it's really
important like i said earlier removing
that self-judgment
or that self-sabotage talk that can move
us in the direction of
i should have discovered this we should
have been doing this we messed up we
lost out on all these opportunities
after that we can we we start
disconnecting and silencing that voice
it's really important to me to accept
well what
is the pathway or the plan to move
towards making this a reality right now
like what does this
actually mean what do i actually need to
do
who do i need to become what do i need
to learn and that's a really important
step for me
and and throughout the last you know
probably 10 to 15 years where i've been
really in this space of of going
internal
i found that there are almost five
stages to anything
and they are learn experiment
perform struggle thrive
and i imagine this danica as a sort of
pyramid
so you have learn at the bottom and
learn
so if you look at the bottom of a
pyramid that's the widest part that's
the base
most of our life should be spent
learning the things we think we need to
learn and a lack of confidence
a lack of certainty increased overwhelm
and a lack of confidence all comes from
a lack of learning
because as soon as you learn to do
something you feel more comfortable with
it
and when you're not learned in an area
that's when you don't feel comfortable
with it so learning is the base
the next level is experimenting when i
learn something the next thing i try and
do straight away is let me experiment
with this new discovery i found and that
again is thinking like a child
because when a child comes across a
spade or a spoon or whatever it may be
they're just experimenting what can they
hit it on what does it sound like or
what do i dig with this what
how much weight can this carry it's like
you're just experimenting and being
playful with it
and so now i've had this discovery or
this realization i'm like okay let me
experiment with it
and then the third thing is i get into a
pattern or a routine where i'm like oh
this makes sense
this works i start performing the same
activity because i can see the result
it's creating
and the natural thing that comes in life
is this struggle so it's like okay i
found my rhythm and then all of a sudden
i lost it again
what do i need to learn again to get
back to that and the final tip of the
pyramid
is thrive because the awards the success
as you know
in in your incredible career and your
success in your journey
that's just like the tip of the pyramid
like that you don't even ex you
experience that for like 0.01
uh sorry 0.01 of the time that's not
something you
experience on a daily basis right and so
to me
that journey is is usually what comes
from a point of self-discovery that's
usually how i
how i process it
i hope that answers your question so
yeah it kind of does i mean like i i
think specific examples are always
interesting because
a lot of this language while you know if
you're versed in it and practiced and
understanding it
and you've read a lot listened to a lot
listened to a lot of you read a lot of
you know
amazing books you know you this is not
this is easier to understand but i think
there's a lot of people that hear it and
they're just hearing a lot of words you
know like it's
it's hard no i'm just i think it's real
examples and like
what happens when someone irritates you
walking down the street
and you know or or what happens when
your partner
makes you angry or what happens when you
know politics is bothering you or
whatever like
how what is it what is that you know
what is that
process like you know yeah well i think
that's part of the challenge too danica
that
we're looking for quick immediate
instant
specific fixes when actually the real
challenge is there's a big root issue
and what i mean by that is like i'll
give it so let's let's get i get really
practical and tactical in the book so
i'm i'm always happy to go all in on
real experiences and
and i agree with you that a lot of this
can become language and vocabulary
uh but the reason why it's important is
let's say you hate your job
and you decide that you're gonna plan a
holiday or a vacation
or go to coachella or you know you're
gonna do something fun this weekend
to try and forget about it or you drink
alcohol to numb yourself from the pain
or you distract yourself with just
spending time with friends
those are all pretty poor attempts at
trying to solve the fact that you don't
like your job
um but we do that we look for that
instant fix that instant solution what's
that habit what's the hack what's that
activity
and actually it's it's it's an internal
uh disconnect that you're actually
trying to solve and so
i'm more than let's dive into certain
examples but the question you asked
around
you know how do you uh what do i do when
i introspect so i'll give you what i
came up with so i was
it was the beginning of the pandemic i
was
watching tv for the first time in a long
time i don't really watch
tv at all and one of the things i chose
to watch was the michael jordan
documentary which i think a lot of
people ended up watching
which funnily enough wasn't a michael
jordan documentary i think it was a
documentary about the
the chicago bulls uh the last dance so i
was watching that
and i was watching it and a really big
lesson hit me
and and it was personal and perfect for
me and it may be totally irrelevant to
someone else listening but but for me
it's relevant
and there was a season in which
michael jordan kept getting to the
playoffs and they were losing
and they couldn't get to the finals they
weren't quite breaking through
and michael jordan at that time realized
that the thing holding him back
and what was holding the chicago bulls
back is they didn't have the depth of
squad they didn't have the right team
next to him
and i believe it was the season after
where they went and got the dennis
rodman's he went and invested in
scottie pippen and he went and invested
in developing
uh steve kerr and he was almost like
trying to build that squad of superstars
around him
so that they could achieve their results
and i was watching this
and in my own way i was observing and
introspecting and asking myself do i
feel
like i'm surrounded by people that help
me grow in particular
areas of my life so i have my spiritual
mentors and counselors
uh do i have the right people around me
in my career do i have the right people
around me and my purpose
do i have the right people around me i
really started to ask that question
deeply after many years of
having gone through that exercise and so
i was learning i was the first thing i
was learning i was like
am i around the right people am i
surrounded by what is wrong
what is it about the people that i have
around me that may not be a 10 out of 10
why is it a six uh what have i done
to not attract the right energy around
me maybe
i've done something that hasn't created
that or maybe i've not been cognizant of
it
and so that was my process of getting
this amazing discovery and rather
than going wow i should have been
figuring this out two years ago which is
that disconnect
my response was well let me go and learn
so i spent
pretty much the last four to six months
learning about
team building leadership managing
inspiring connecting with people
because i'm at a certain stage in my
life where that's demanding of me
as opposed to what was divided on me
three years ago so to me
that was a very practical thing that i
had to deal with
which came from a very philosophical
experience of watching this show
yeah but it was like okay and so if we
get into things like
i'm happy to dive into any specifics so
you give me a specific uh
challenge and we'll go straight into it
this is exactly what i was curious about
like how
it goes for you a real life example of
like something because
you know that's the thing is it's like i
think that it's difficult
for us when we're sitting in our own
shoes to really recognize
um situations that come up so sometimes
yeah
it comes through watching a documentary
sometimes it comes through
driving down the road sometimes it comes
through um
you know like when you have to spend a
week with your parents or something you
know like you don't know when it's going
to come through but it can come through
in so many various different ways and so
sort of unpacking the way that it goes
for you when there's that introspection
and that sort of aha moment of like
maybe b is like
what's next right that's the thing is it
i think i you know i read
in your book the the why game i think
that's a fantastic
exam like it's a very easy
process for how to start to try and
unpack
some of that stuff yeah so that's i'm
really glad you brought that up so
that so it's called the y ladder or the
y game as you said
in the book and i have been talking
about that
in line with what's happening in the
last eight months so i'll give an
example
uh with me and my wife we both are born
and raised in london we currently live
in la so
our parents and our sisters and from my
wife's side my niece and nephew
and my brother-in-law all back in london
and when we
found out the news that lockdown was
happening at the beginning of the
pandemic
and we wouldn't be allowed to fly back
to london because countries had closed
their borders
the first thing that me and my wife
feared was
the safety of our parents our parents
are older they're getting older and we
were worried about them
and the first fear in my mind was oh my
god what if something happens to my
parents what's going to happen
like you know i'm really scared about
that like how will they be safe what if
they get covered
right very normal fear but with that i
asked i use the y ladder so i asked
myself well
why am i scared of that like why do i
fear that
and then my mind came up with another
answer and the answer was well i'm
scared of that because
i want to see my parents and i love my
parents and what if something happens to
them and i don't get to see them and i
don't get to be with them and
and i don't get to be around them and i
don't get to love them
and so then i ask myself again after
listening to that dialogue
why am i scared of that then my mind
comes up with another answer and it says
and he's coming up with a deeper answer
every time and it comes up with the
answer of like
well i'm scared because i love my
parents and
i want them to know i love them and i
want to spend time with them and i want
to see them
and i want them to know how much they
mean to me and then i ask myself one
last time
why am i scared of that and the answer
that came to me
literally changed how i felt the last
eight months and my wife
the answer was for me i'm not showing
them enough love right now
and that's something i can actually do
something about
i can't stop them from getting covered i
can't i can tell them to be safe which
they have been
but what i can actually do is call them
facetime them message them
communicate with them and tell them i
love them show them i love them maybe
send them their favorite thing
during this time that will help them i
can show them
what i'm actually scared so what i'm
actually scared about
is not that they're unsafe due to
coverage what i'm really scared about is
i'm not showing them love right now
and so that's a practical way of turning
an anxiety
into a point of action and doing
something about it rather than getting
lost in things i can't control which is
i can't open up the borders i can't
visit london and i can't save them from
this disease i love how you explain
to look at fear uh and
sort of welcome it as a part of the
process
and as something motivating as opposed
to
something that you just need to like
push down or shove out or
not have and you know then that includes
judgment and all kinds of things i think
that that's
so refreshing yeah i think you know
i i think that we've just been trained
as kids to
either distract avoid or numb our fears
and pain
so it's like oh you're scared of
something distract yourself you're
scared of something just avoid it
and when you distract yourself avoid
from it distract yourself from it
it's going to come back in some way if
you avoid it it's just going to amplify
and if you numb
yourself so a lot of us just try and
numb ourselves from our fear
and so what i often say to people is
like we we all have two choices like you
either
escape your fears or you elevate and see
them from a different
lens and from a different space and for
me that comes with that intimacy of
trying to ask yourself why am i scared
of this
and what can i do about it and and
getting close to your fear
is is the only way to remove fear of the
unknown i'll give it a really basic
example if you're scared of
uh a dark room in your house if you
don't go and check that dark room every
night you're going to be scared of it
forever and so you have to approach it
and so you may be scared of like you
were saying earlier which danny i'm so
glad that you're
i really appreciate you pushing me and
you and this conversation into a
practical space
but let's say you're scared of having a
conversation with your partner right
if you don't have that conversation if
you don't understand
why you're scared of it and start
breaking it down you're going to be the
best fiction writer in the world
writing nightmare stories in your mind
of what that could mean how it could go
how they may react
and now you've just wasted a ton of
energy whereas if you just ask yourself
why am i scared and you realize
i'm scared because i may lose them if i
tell them this
then the question you ask yourself is
well how do i share it with them
in a way they know i don't want to lose
them but i still need to address this
so you're almost reframing the
conversation because you
understand your fear rather than i don't
understand my fear i'm scared of losing
them so i'm just not going to
address it at all um that kind of leads
me into some other thoughts i've been
having too
about um judgment and so
i was watching a video and it was sort
of
framing judgment as being a reflection
of something that you're denying in
yourself
and i thought that that was just like it
was a moment for me i was like
yes because for me like let's say i
judge
i judge people that are lazy i just do
and when i unpack that and realize that
okay
looking at it from that perspective of
is this something that i deny in myself
being lazy and the answer is uh-huh
i completely do um so
i i think judgment is another thing that
leads us down a path that's so similar
to that
fear and that um you know uh all those
things that
uh are hiding underneath that help us
really learn about ourselves because
it's an inside job right
yeah and the the only way and what you
just said is beautiful and i couldn't
agree with you more
the only way you remove judgment
is turning it into observation and
noticing so you're always going to have
an opinion on stuff
not having an opinion is actually not
realistic
so everyone has an opinion you will
always have an opinion
but your opinion can either turn into a
judgment which is usually
fatalistic and kind of a bit
it's it's almost like a conclusion
whereas
an observation is a starting point
so judgment is like oh i don't like lazy
people or i look down on lazy people
it's like conclusive it's like there's
an end to that thought
whereas a observation is a starting
thought which is like
let me explore laziness and why this
person may be lazy
uh because i observe that they're lazy i
have an opinion that this person's lazy
but let me explore why they may be lazy
or
what's made them that way that's the
beginning of a conversation and a
beginning of a relationship
well you said monks ask questions right
yes yes monks do they ask
questions i think that's beautiful yeah
that's the only i mean i
i think more and more i've realized even
with myself like i spend
most of my days asking myself questions
and you're doing it right now as an
interviewer
asking people questions and i i think
that we all don't ask ourselves enough
questions like we don't check in with
ourself enough we don't
we don't actually know and the what you
were saying earlier is that
only by switching off the conscious mind
can you
actually hear the subconscious of how
you actually
feel and and a very practical example of
that is
if you're running around busy in life
and hectic
and you're just moving around and
frantically your body
won't even allow you to fall sick
what happens is as soon as you stop
your body shuts down have you ever had
that before oh that i mean like
everyone has right right you're working
really hard you're busy
you're not falling sick you're hacking
it you're getting through and then all
of a sudden you take that week off
you fall sick straight away because you
finally gave your body
the time and space to do what it needed
to do
so same with your mind if your mind's
always on
and you don't pause and find that
stillness in the day in whatever way you
do
your subconscious doesn't get a chance
you'll find that if you stop and even if
i stop right now
and we just take a couple of seconds and
i'm not meditating i'm just checking in
with myself and i'm checking in and
going
all right what do i feel right now my
mouth's dry
i feel a bit dehydrated and i'm quite
comfortable in this chair
and so i straight away my body and mind
have made me aware of things that i may
not be aware if i talk through this
whole podcast and this whole
conversation
without checking in with myself i don't
actually know there you go i don't
actually know
and so many of us don't check in with
ourselves all year round
well that's kind of shedding light on
two really big pillars i would imagine
of
being a monk or being someone spiritual
or being someone that's able to do that
and that's
breath and meditation
yeah i i'm a big believer in at least at
the beginning of
you know meditation just being this
opportunity to check in with yourself
like you're checking your notifications
you're checking your updates you're
checking in with your partner your kids
and going like
how are you doing how's it going are you
okay what do you need and it's almost
like just having that with yourself
is is the beginning of all meditation
because you're giving
your body and mind and your subconscious
an opportunity to communicate with you
and they often know what you don't know
because your conscious intellect and
mind is so
strong and conditioned and patterned and
harmonized that you're just working from
that place whereas when you slow down
you give an opportunity like we said
with the body making you sick or
with the body and mind helping you with
what you're really struggling with
and so i find like that centeredness
comes through
stillness and there's a beautiful uh a
tibetan buddhist leader has this
beautiful
uh statement he said that he said that
what movement does for your body
stillness does for your mind
and and i found that to be so profound
because we all know the feeling that we
get when we exercise when we move when
we dance when we work out
we know what like our body feels amazing
from that movement
but imagine what are we it's actually
the opposite for our mind we need that
stillness and space so i encourage a lot
of people
very practically to find stillness and
space and when i see students in space i
don't mean you need to be on a mountain
top i don't need mean you need to be in
a yoga class
what i mean is you need to find five
minutes a day
where you just get to check in with
yourself and hear it listen
and observe uh without having a negative
judgment yeah
absolutely i've finally started
meditating
for the good five or six months now
pretty much every day
um and it's it's beautiful i mean and
and
with meditation of course there's
there's days where you get
these huge downloads and transmissions
and things happen and you're like
wow that's 5d that's amazing
and then there are times where you're
like so i sat there and i just thought
about stuff for a while
um totally and that's great like it's
the same as like sometimes you eat
dinner and you're like that was the best
meal i ever had
and sometimes you had dinner and you're
like that meal just kept me alive like
you know it's
like that for you even being a monk like
does that happen to you too
it's it's uh it's harder and harder so
i've been meditating now for a total of
15 years
um for two hours a day for 15 years and
when i was about like two hours total or
like an hour
most of the uh the rule is two hours a
day in a row
the exception is when i'm traveling or
i woke up early for work and then my my
my schedule gets disjointed and then
that's 30 minutes four blocks each
throughout the day got it got it got it
so it does change now when i was a monk
it was we used to do something four to
eight hours in a row and so that was
very much
you know deep discipline based i don't
have as many meditations anymore
that i don't find to be um
you know that i don't find to be useful
and
way bigger that's amazing by the way i
mean that's beautiful
it is really beautiful and it's just
been so long that doesn't mean that i
easily slot into it every day so if i'm
jet lagged and i'm tired
and i'm moving around then you know i
get challenged too
and that's what i often say to people is
that the two hours is not an achievement
the the point is that you need to give
it enough time for your mind to quiet
down so if you think about
like switching off your laptop before
your laptop switches off it asks you
like 10 questions
like do you want to open up these files
when you restart the laptop do you want
to turn off this
and it's like that's what your mind is
doing so when you're turning down your
mind when you're switching off your mind
your mind's like oh wait a minute you
haven't done this or what about this
to-do list
and you've just got to wait for that to
calm down it's the same as when you turn
a fan
off it keeps spinning for a while right
right the fan doesn't just switch off
and so with our minds we expect it to
like
switch off at the click of a button even
your iphone doesn't switch off and
switch on
at the click of a button it still takes
a moment and so giving your mind that
patience to just
all right let me hear these thoughts out
let me write that to-do list
and so sometimes that can take me longer
than other
times but as soon as you're past that
that's when you're in you know and and i
think we just have to write analogy
such a great analogy it's so true um
can you do you have any um story you'd
like to share about some amazing
transmission that came through some
amazing download
yeah why not uh i think one of my
uh best experiences with meditation
happened in a temple in south india
and this is partly the method that i
talk about in the book called location
has
energy so i do believe that when you're
in certain environments
and you create certain environments in
your home
they can allow you to access
depth quicker and so and very
practically before i dive into that
story
i talk about how sight sense and sounds
are three easy windows into being state
shifters
so uh for example site when you look at
something when i look at a piece of art
when i look at the wonderful dress that
you're wearing on top that you're
wearing when i look at
the plants in your background that sight
has a certain trigger when you look at
the frames behind me and the people that
are in them
it's like those i don't just have these
because they look cool i have them
because they
invoke a certain feeling inside of me
when i walk into this room and so my
question to people is
what is the first thing you see when you
wake up in the morning is it a work of
art is it a quote is it a
paragraph in your favorite book uh when
you walk into your
office what's the first thing that you
see when you walk into your living room
what's the first thing that you see
because
i promise you that you can sight design
your life so that you are inspired at
every moment or you feel what you want
to feel
based on sight they become like living
mantras
you walk around i mean like no different
than like a a bracelet or something you
wear that's significant as you're like
you know this bracelet means this
they're like mantras
yeah that's that's exactly it and i
think surrounding ourselves with
physical triggers visual triggers
of things that help us feel certain
things like if we're like oh you know
what whenever it gets to 3 p.m
i just get really tired and exhausted or
you know what when i wake up
in the morning i'm just not inspired at
all
well why don't you start changing what
you look at when you wake up in the
morning so
studies show that 80 of us look at our
phones first thing in the morning and
the last thing at night
so we're looking at our phones before we
see our partners and our kids and
we look at our phones lasting at night
after we see our partners and our kids
and guess what when you look at your
phone you're looking at news
notifications negativity and noise
so you spend the you start your day at a
minus four and you spend the rest of
your day trying to climb up to zero
which which is you're already setting
yourself up for a harder journey and so
your visual trigger so that's one the
second one is the trigger
of a scent and this is so underestimated
and i actually learned this
as as monks we obviously had a lot of
incense candles
uh you know natural fragrances that were
around us and we were encouraged to
appreciate the the true fragrance and a
flower and to be mindful with it and sit
with it and
immerse with that experience and i found
this a few years ago after i married my
wife
and what she did is she and i didn't i
didn't realize that this was exactly
what we learned as monks but she made it
very practical hence i'm sharing it
she had different diffusers and
essential oils and candles burning in
different rooms in the home
so when i would walk into the living
room i would breathe in
and it would be like lavender and i
would automatically for calm and when i
walked into the bedroom it would be
sandalwood
and when i would read that in that would
remind me of sleep and so what i found
is that you can actually
scent design your life away from stress
because why is it that when you walk
into a spa
or a massage therapy space that you feel
relaxed it's usually the scent
you breathe in sandalwood lavender
eucalyptus and
all of a sudden so every morning when
i'm in a shower i'll put a few drops of
eucalyptus
and just breathe in and out and you will
just feel it different like it is
chemically affecting you right it's
literally chemical but chemically
biologically shifting your state
and so for me that's been a huge one
and the third one is sound design uh i i
researched this when
again as monks like you said mantra we
would chant mantras we would
hear mantras we would hear gongs people
associate monks and gongs there's a
reason because the vibration from a gong
are all crystal balls there we go there
we go oh i love them
it's uh it's all seven seven chakras
plus the eighth
so oh i love that that's amazing i had
no idea well there you go so that's a
perfect example of like
the power of frequency and vibration
and so i was saying the same to people
in life today it's like
how many of us have a playlist for our
ideal day
like what's the sound you want to wake
up to in the morning to get you inspired
what's the sound you want to hear in the
evening to help you wind down
what's the sound you want to hear at 3
p.m it could be nature sounds it could
be gongs it could be singing bowls it
could be sound balls it could be
your favorite song by taylor swift what
like you know it doesn't matter what it
is but
why have we not created a playlist for
our day
and these are really simple basic life
changes that anyone can do to shift
their state throughout the day
and the challenge is most of us are
exposed to insignificant sound so
i used to live in new york city and i
always questioned why i felt tired
sometimes at the end of the day
and i've discovered or reset something
called cognitive load
and what this theory was suggesting is
that when you're listening to drilling
phones sirens uh you know what would be
considered as
insignificant irrelevant sound you're
not that in new york
yeah exactly new york your brain is
trying to make
sense of that sound but there is no
sense
to it so your brain is wasting energy
known as cognitive load your brain's
load is being wasted
80 on insignificant sound and so hence
if you are traveling i mean not many
people are right now but headphones and
travel or
listening to a podcast like danica's or
an audiobook
or your favorite song like just any
of that uh anyway so that was a long
winded practical answer to what you
asked me about a meditation experience
but i'll get into that once
we share this yeah well that was i mean
that was
that that's going to lead me to another
question i totally want to hear your
down like
some fascinating uh
uh amazing sort of quantum field
experience
but um but it makes me think of right
off
right then is is this is for people too
think about how much you know
you know like yes there's those ambient
noises but what if there's people what
if people complain
and they don't actually want to think it
says you write about that in the book
it's like
some people don't want to figure their
problems out they're just there to
complain so
you know those to me sound like the same
thing
it could be the news which to me is just
distraction
so like that's you can't
use logic to solve something illogical
and there's a lot of things that go on
whether they're in the news or whether
that's in our life or someone
complaining
that it's illogical and so when you try
to apply logic you're just
wasting your energy absolutely that's so
well said i
i couldn't agree with you more and that
idea of
us taking responsibility because
so i talked about the three as i was
taught the three cancers
of the mind which are complaining
comparing and criticizing
the complaining comparing and
criticizing are at lower frequencies and
vibration
right so if you're trying to operate
from the point of view of like
being a growth mindset person being a
person who wants to help others
being a good person that vibration is
bringing you down and that doesn't mean
that you reject people who do that or
you don't care about them and you just
push them away
but it's you also recognizing that if
you have a different goal you're not
going to be able to achieve that from
this frequency and vibration
now you may get to a point in your life
where you're strong enough to lift
people up
but until you're at that level you know
you're going to get pulled down and i
often think about
the idea of if you saw someone drowning
in the sea if you were lifeguard
qualified you'd go and save them but if
you weren't you'd go look for the
lifeguard
and you'd go lifeguard can you come and
please save that person because you knew
that you would just get pulled down
anyway
and so real compassion isn't just
staying
in a complaining culture community real
compassion
is introducing your community to the
teachings the wisdom the guides the
coaches the mentors
that can help everyone out of that
drowning state
and often we look at false compassion
and false compassion he's like
oh no i just have to stay there with
this person and help them out but
hey what if you stayed with that person
in the drowning sea and you both just
drowned that's not good for either of
you
and so it's important to recognize that
uh but but yeah going back to that
the the experience that i had so this
temple in south india
and south india has some stunning
temples and you can just google south
indian temples and you see the
architecture is just phenomenal
some of these temples are like two to
five thousand years old
so they are all like they are you know
the the brick work
the the brick i don't even think bricks
the bricks
the stone work sorry and and the
architecture is just phenomenal
and when i was inside those spaces
uh you just you you genuinely feel
transported to another realm
it's almost like watching i don't know
if you've ever watched doctor strange
uh and and if you haven't then i
recommend watching doctor stranger has a
lot of brilliant philosophical messages
but
in that movie you almost imagine being
in a different realm
even in the world and there's one temple
in south india that has this
incredible corridor which is like
pillars and pillars and pillars and
pillars and pillars
and and you can meditate in that
corridor and in that corridor it
literally feels like it's a gateway to
another dimension
and so there were parts of that
meditation where i literally felt
like i was being transported
dimensionally through and when you when
you just look at the picture you will
you will feel it just by looking at it
you don't even need to be a meditator
but when you meditate there you can
truly feel
the most outer body experiences that you
could possibly have and
a big part of uh the teachings that i
studied is the recognition that we are
not this body that we are something
beyond this body we are consciousness
and and that having that experience for
me
of feeling outside of and more than my
body uh it's probably the deepest
experiences i've ever had with
meditation
um that i can share of that genuine
feeling that i'm not my body and this is
just a
container and a vessel in a vehicle and
that i'm a consciousness
beyond this and so are you and so is
everyone else and
experiencing that is pretty pretty
special and remarkable and uh
watching it were you watching yourself
or were you
purely transcended as in like
there was no awareness for for jay with
you know the blue jacket and the what
like there's no awareness for the body
that you're in
like as in you felt a part of
everything is that am i yes correct so
yeah so a good example from other
experiences often we would meditate in
uh extreme cold or heat and and the
purpose of that was to
when you're in that much physical pain
you have no choice but to go
inward and so it's almost like
you enter into the inner world and the
inner universe
of the the connectedness between
everything so you're no longer
feeling the physical connection with the
body like right now i'm sitting i can
feel that i'm sitting
yeah and i can feel that my leg you know
i've crossed my legs because i've always
feel comfortable when i cross my legs on
chairs than sitting with my legs down
and so but i can feel that i'm doing
that i'm conscious of it
whereas my point is losing that physical
consciousness of yourself
to not feel like you're even sitting
here to not
feel like you're in this physical space
to really experience that has probably
been one of my favorite experiences of
meditation and
i don't try and and the goal isn't to
feel that like that's not
right that's where people get confused
like i don't meditate
to feel that uh when you meditate purely
and deeply you experience that as a
byproduct and so
it was very much very clearly explained
to us that you're not meditating to
be powerful or gain powers or gain
these mystic abilities that's not the
point like you meditate to build up the
deepest connection with yourself and
others in the universe
and a byproduct of that is that you may
experience this
a little non-locality yes um
i've been thinking about um you know
we're talking about distraction we're
talking about
feeling things in our body um
getting in touch with that pausing
stillness
and so a thought that i've been having
is that
we don't know what to trust anymore we
don't know what news to trust we don't
know what
movies or documentaries to trust like
what's propaganda who paid for it
um you know what's really real
going on in the world and so i just have
this thought that
we're entering this new a new sort of
phase of existence where and i'm curious
if you
what you think about this or if you've
thought about it
is that we're being asked to
go inward and to learn how to feel into
our body
to learn how to be able to then discern
truth from lies
through resonance in
our body in the awareness and the
knowing that we
that arrives through situations um
because that's all we have left now and
that this is
i feel as a very untapped
unending potential yes
yes i i i'm so glad you brought that up
uh
i think the ability to be independently
thoughtful
has been lost on the desire to be
consumed by the direction of society
we've almost
let society direct us and guide us
and we all know that and we know it
happens in many different ways
and you know one of one of the funniest
ones for me was
uh i remember when i was proposing to my
wife which was about
six years ago now when she was my you
know when she was my girlfriend and not
my wife
and i remember asking my
guy friends who'd proposed about you
know where do you buy a diamond ring and
how where how much do you
pay for it and all that kind of stuff
and
i remember looking into it and they told
me that jay
you know you buy a diamond ring you can
buy from this shop uh
and you know these are the kind of cuts
you're looking for and you usually spend
two months salary on it like that was
the
rule of thumb that i was given by all
these people and i started looking into
it and i was reading about it and this
was actually more
like probably a few years ago not not
during that time and i bought the ring i
proposed to all the rest of it
and then i came across this this study
or this this article that i was reading
and it was talking about how actually
that idea came from the diamond
industry so diamonds were not even used
to propose to people
until the 20th century
and they were not a part of that culture
but the diamond industry
wanted to make diamonds more integrated
into obviously a big human decision of
getting married
and therefore they were marketed in that
way and literally if you go on youtube
you can die type in de beers commercial
and de beers actually has a diamond
commercial not only does it say a
diamond is forever and show the love
between a man and a woman and a proposal
but literally at the end of the advent
i'm not kidding you it says
how else can you make two months salary
last forever like literally in those
words
and i was shocked because i was thinking
this
culture from de beers advertising
has stemmed all the way into my friends
in london who are all south like those
people that i asked were south asians
i people are my my background in descent
and how is and none of them know why
like when i was like why do you spend
two months salary they're like oh no
that's just you know rule of thumb like
as if it was like a fact
and and you know even today it's like we
all think about diamond rings when you
think about getting married no one goes
are we going to get a
gold ring are we going to get this like
everyone thinks of diamond rings but
that was literally programmed into
society so
we've all been programmed in different
ways but the interesting thing about
that
is just as we got programmed to ask a
diamond ring why did we never ask
ourselves
well what would be the sweetest way to
propose to my partner
right like why why would i not think of
the most unique
special way to propose with an item that
why does it have to be a ring but
we never asked that question because we
adopted a pattern of society and so
i would encourage everyone and and i
think that's what you're doing and i
love that
is to ask to to study to read to
research
i think that's very important and i'm a
big believer in
you know timeless and ancient wisdom
having so many answers
uh that that uh correlate with modern
science and that's what think like
amongst based on i
basically went and found all the
scientific studies
that back that back the activities of
monks that have been done for thousands
of years
and so i love the the synergy between
ancient wisdom and modern science
but at the same time the third part of
that synergy
is how does that fit with me right and
and i think that that question is the
question that's been missing and
to me that starts with the simplest
thing like when you watch a movie or you
eat some food
ask yourself did i like that movie yes
or no
what did i like about that movie why did
i like it if you ask yourself those
three questions after eating something
watching a movie meeting a person
i promise you your self-awareness will
go through the roof
but usually what we do when we meet
someone is we meet them we hang out we
have fun and then we never think about
it we never actually take a moment to
reflect
but if you literally just do that like
wait a minute did i like that movie yes
or no did i like hanging around with
that group of people yes or no okay what
did i like about it
why did i like it or not and if you
simply do that after every activity or
experience your self-awareness will rise
so much
that the quality of your intuition will
be so strong
that your intuition will start to guide
you it reminds me of a simple
like instagram quote i saw many times
which is i think it's something like
stop saying yes to [ __ ] you hate
because how many times do we do stuff
that we're like oh i
well yeah i do it because i'm programmed
they do it because i have to
but do i am doing it because oh my god i
hate doing that
so true and and i think that
understanding that we have a choice
and and often what we do is we get
overwhelmed and we go oh no there's just
too much and nothing's true
or and and that feels like the easy way
out or sometimes
the easy way out is either nothing's
true and nothing's real
or the other easy way out is
everything's true and everything's real
so i follow everyone and everything
or i follow nothing and actually what we
need is that middle ground of
finding the groups of people we take
advice from the mentors the council the
coach
the the things we do value because we
all need that
but also keeping a healthy ability to
question that
and look beyond it so it's almost like
there's a loyalty
but there's also the the ability to
learn even within that loyalty
yeah loyalty the things that you
question
um as well it reminds me of another
thing that i've seen um
a religion called omnism where you don't
believe in any one religion but that
there's truth in all of them
oh nice yeah i i mean i would agree with
that i think that that's uh
i i think the essence of of all
spiritual and religious practices
ultimately are
exactly the same uh and and often
yeah what's blocking us is is
far more our laziness coming back to
what you are saying
uh is our laziness to commit to anything
and that's why we go oh yeah i don't
believe in any of it because that's also
a sense of
i don't have to commit i don't have to
work i don't have to do anything about
it yeah
why are you spiritual would you call
yourself spiritual or would you call
yourself religious
i'm not i'm not trying to get it
why do you follow this path yeah i would
call myself spiritual for sure
but i i think i'm in a space where i
value both spirituality and science
and steps in strategy quite equally
so i kind of see them as part of my past
so my path is
and and that's what the book does and
that's what all parts of my life is my
path is and any content i create or
anything
my path is like what's the spiritual
perspective what's the scientific
perspective
and now what are the steps and
strategies to help people live it and
help me live it
and so i think like life is like so much
more about embracing
polarities and paradoxes as opposed to
like i'm spiritual or i'm scientific
i'm strategic or i'm sincere to me it's
like i want to be strategic spiritual
and scientific because that's
the mix that helps me live the reason i
i followed this path is
i was very fortunate when i was 18 to
obviously
connect with monks to connect with
spiritual people
and in you know i've been really
fortunate in my life to meet
such a wide array of people everyone
from
when we were monks you know serving
homeless communities
helping build sustainable villages
feeding children with
nothing in india on the streets all the
way through to
having met and spent time with
billionaires and
and famous individuals and coaching and
working with people
of literally people from all different
backgrounds and walks of life
all across that spectrum and
materialism just doesn't have any
answers
just just simply put like materialism
has zero answers the
the material pursuit of
success and happiness in and of itself
is
limited and ultimately i've seen people
whether they've conquered it or are
trying to conquer it
have ultimately turned to spirituality
in in every sense so
not only from my own experience have i
had amazing spiritual experiences
but from having observed human
experience
material things are a need a necessity
and
are useful and important but they are
not the goal
and so we you know i don't idolize or
demonize materialism
um because i live in the world i make
money i'm an entrepreneur i have a home
i have a car
i value all of those things but i don't
value those things to give me a sense of
happiness
joy fulfilment or purpose but i do value
them as they are
as tools and energy and so i think
the reason i chose the spiritual path
and continue to do so
is because i see people of all different
backgrounds and walks of life
ultimately turning in that direction uh
regardless of what they've achieved or
what they haven't achieved
so encapsulates sort of the burning
desire in you
like that's right going daddy keep going
yeah like it you know
truth or what would it be just like uh
waking up waking people up or would it
be
um you know what would it what is the
what is the
purpose of it all the purpose of it all
is simple it's
it's i found a way of life that brought
a great deal of fulfillment and purpose
to mine
so i feel a sense of responsibility to
pass it on it's like having just
if you just found the cure to cancer
you'd want to share it with everyone if
if
you found it because you never want
people to suffer so i feel like
i found the cure to a lot of our issues
and challenges and i found them through
these amazing teachers
and so i feel a bit of a weight of
responsibility
in a positive sense to pass them along
because if i didn't
i'd feel like i'd done a disservice to
the people that helped me and the people
that served me because
what if we could help everyone remove
their suffering or limit their suffering
and
navigate their suffering actually as
opposed to just saying oh yeah i found a
way out of mind
and you know good for me and and i'll
let you figure out on your own and
like like you know i think me and you
both agree with this there are multiple
paths there are multiple ideas
uh there's many different teachers and
guides and coaches and whatever it may
be
and when i started out i just really
wanted to share what i'd learned and
that's what i've been doing ever since
and
thankfully it's helped people and
they've you know they've connected with
it but
i never had any imagination or desire
close
that the the impact that's been made so
far is
anything that we would ever have got to
so it's it's a blessing and i'm humbled
and grateful for every day
it reminds me of what i've said so much
in the last
probably a year is that we're all just
walking each other home
i love that that's beautiful that's so
good that's such a beautiful vision
you know it's but it is it's like
somebody could be like oh my gosh thank
you for doing that you're like don't
worry about it we're all just walking
each other home you know
that is such a beautiful visual thank
you for that you've just given me a huge
gift i love that
i love it and some people of course like
yourself
are you know playing really big roles in
that
and taking that responsibility on and
you know i speak for so many people when
i say thank you
thank you for sharing thank you for um
going in
so that you can put it out there what
you're doing
and give us all tools because i mean i
mean if that's one thing that i've
learned so far in this book is there's
like
so many tools i was just saying before
we started
to my producer i was like i think you
could take like each chapter and make it
a month
of your life because there's so much
applicable information in here
and so much so but so much training i
could train your mind for peace and
purpose every day like
it is a reprogramming and so like this
could literally be your guide for the
year
and um so thank you for thank you for
writing this book thank you for sharing
and um you know i hope this is the first
of many conversations we have
yeah well no thank you for for doing
what you do and and thank you for
pushing me at the beginning to to be
more specific and practical i love that
and
i'm grateful to you for that because uh
i couldn't agree with you more right
the last thing i want to do is is speak
in uh
intangibles and so thank you for
encouraging me to do that and
and uh recommending us to that today
because i think that hopefully will help
people and
and yeah it's uh you know i i think
everyone
i genuinely believe and you know this
you you've you've achieved so much of
this in your life and i
can't wait to learn more about where
your mind space and heart space is right
now
but you know everyone does have a unique
purpose and calling and this
book begins with my favorite verse from
the bhagavad-gita which says
it's better to follow your own path
imperfectly
than to follow another's perfectly
and to me that is the root of all of our
growth or issues because i'm just trying
to follow my path the best i can
i genuinely feel i'm doing what i was
meant to be doing and what i was born to
do and
and i feel very aligned in that sense
and it's taken me a long time to get
here and i'm still trying to constantly
align every day it's not like it's done
and it's achieved
and and i just want everyone to align
with their greatest calling because we
need
everyone in this world and to live that
way we don't just need a few people we
need everyone to feel aligned with their
purpose and their
their calling so thank you for allowing
me to share this with your community and
and your audience thank you so much yeah
thank you
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button